So I'll,
I'll tell you a little bit about,
I'll tell you a little bit about Harold
blooms career later in the lecture.
Uh, those of you who know how to
read a poem, the books on religion,
Shakespeare and the
invention of the human, um,
may and PR and perhaps only know those
books may feel a little surprised at
finding him on a literary theory syllabus.
Uh,
but the great outpouring of work
beginning with the anxiety of influence,
the map and bus reading,
poetry and repression, great
many other books in the 70s,
uh,
put bloom in the very midst of the
theoretical controversies then swirling.
He was associated with the
so-called Yale school. In fact,
he was willing to put his name as editor
and also contributor on a volume that
was called deconstruction and criticism.
I think though that even in
reading what you have before your,
you can see how relatively little
bloom has to do with deconstruction.
Uh,
and certainly in his more recent career,
he's distanced himself from a well
from theory. I mean, he, he's,
uh, he hasn't really changed
his views of anything,
although he doesn't any longer read
poems through the machinery of the six
revisionary ratios.
Perhaps I should stop there and say the
six revisionary ratios won't be on the
test. Now, you know, I mean,
I think that nothing could be more
exciting than to understand clean oven
Tessera, you know, sort
of Kinosis us cases,
demonization, appa,
Fraydi's Whoa. You know,
to wander in the realms of these,
uh,
of these ideas and actually to use them
as a machinery for practical criticism,
to take a poem and to see what you can
actually do with these ideas really is,
and I'm serious, uh, an exciting
process. And you may sit,
you may very much resent not having
these six ratios on the exam.
Uh,
and you may wish to hear more about them
and you'll hear something about a few
of them in passing today. But, uh, uh,
if you do wish to hear more about them,
perhaps perhaps your
sections will provide,
provide some guidance. Um, in
any case, in any case, uh, the,
the contributions of bloom,
uh,
to theory in my opinion, and I hope
to bring this out in the long run,
have primarily to do with the fact
that I think he can legitimately and
authentically be called an
important literary historiography.
That is to say together with,
uh,
people like Dan Yanoff and Jakobson,
in earlier in the chorus,
Hans Brobeck yellows later in the course
bloom does seriously deserve to be
considered a literary historian.
That is to say a,
with a theory about literary
history on a par with those,
with those other figures. Uh, uh, it's,
this hasn't always often been remarked.
As a matter of fact, the general,
the general critical attitude toward bloom
is that he's hopelessly a historicist
cares.
Nothing about history,
cares nothing about the way in which the
real world impinges on literature. Um,
and in a certain measure as, as we'll
also see there's some truth in this,
but he has a powerful argument about
the relationship among texts as they
succeed each other in history. Uh,
it's an argument which I think,
which I think really we ignore at
our peril. It's an important one, a,
and it is a psychoanalytic one,
which is,
which is one of the things that places
him at this point in the course,
you'll notice that as we turn,
you know,
you remember the sort of try partition
of the subject matter of our course,
which it's all headed up in the syllabus
and all clearly to be understood.
You know,
first we have logo genesis,
the production of literature by language.
Then we have psycho genesis,
the production of literature
by the human psyche.
Then we have socio genesis,
the production of literature by social,
economic and political and historical
factors. Okay, fine. Well and good.
But you may have noticed how much trouble
we've had getting into psycho genesis.
We keep saying we've
arrived at psycho genesis,
but we actually continue to be working
obviously with linguistic models.
Here's Lacan telling us, you know,
the, uh, the unconscious is a,
resembles a language,
is structured like a language books
telling us that it's the verbal, uh,
structure,
uh,
arising out of the relationship between
metaphor and Matana me that constitutes
the narrative text. And we keep
sitting around twiddling your thumbs,
waiting for somebody to say,
let's now think about the psycho
genesis of the text. Well,
bloom brings us closer,
uh, uh, big and he himself,
you know, when he speaks of the
poet in the poet, uh, is uh, is, is,
is concerned to describe
what he calls an agon,
a psychological agon or struggle between
the belated poet and the precursor,
uh, taking place, uh, at
that level in the psyche.
But even bloom of course is talking
about the relation of texts to text.
He is talking about relations
which are arguably verbal, um,
verbal influenced by the way. Uh,
he always professes contempt for,
he calls it moldy fig philology.
Uh,
but I think that as you study the
examples of literary influence in Bloom's
text, anxiety of influence, map
of minutes reading and so on, uh,
you will see that there is a
kind of dependence on verbal, uh,
Echo,
verbal continuity that his theory,
the strong version of,
of his theory struggles against.
But I think nevertheless does,
does link itself to, and, um,
and I want to move into a general
exploration of the topic of influence by
talking in fact about how unstable
the relationship between an idea of
influence,
which is let's say psychological or a
world based and an idea of influence,
which is word based, uh, can be,
it's not as simple and straightforward
a distinction as one might imagine.
Um, so we're, we,
we linger in these linguistic models and
there's a long tradition in which the,
uh, confusion between the
psychic and the linguistic, uh,
is manifest. And it has to do
with the traditional subject,
the very traditional subject of imitation.
Plato and Aristotle agree that
art poetry is an imitation.
It's, it is both of them
say an imitation of nature.
Plato thinks it's done badly.
Aristotle thinks it's done well,
but they both agree that poetry
is an imitation of nature.
Uh, and then, uh, as time passes,
this idea of mummy says, uh, imitation,
the imitation of nature gradually becomes
transformed so that by the time you
get to the silver age of
a Roman literature, uh,
a high water mark of elegance
in the Latin language,
by the time you get there,
you have rhetorical theorists
like quintile in and Cicero
and others talking not
about [inaudible], but
about in Latin. Of course,
any Tatio same idea seemingly that
they're still talking about imitation.
But the strange thing that's happened
is now they're not talking about the
invitation of nature anymore.
They're talking about the imitation
of literary models. In other words,
the imitation of language.
Uh,
the way in which we can establish cannons
by thinking about the relationship of
particular poets and other writers with
a tradition of literary expression,
uh, from which they
emerge. So this then he,
me Tacho becomes a language
based theory of influence,
uh,
or Ising seemingly spontaneously out
of a nature based theory of influence.
Now take a look at the first
passage on your sheet, uh,
from Alexander Pope's essay on criticism.
He's talking about Virgil here.
Homer, the argument is, has to
have imitated nature. After all,
there were no literary models to imitate.
So of homer imitated anything.
It must've been nature. Well,
fine, homer imitated nature.
But then along comes Virgil in
this same period of, by the way,
when a rhetorical theories,
we're redefining imitation
as the invitation of verbal
models along comes verb
Virgil. Then he says, I'm going
to write my own national epic. Uh,
and you know what,
I'll just sit down and write it.
But then he starts looking at homer.
This is all what the pope is thinking as
he prepares to write the cup that's on
here. She, uh, he said that he then,
you know, he's, he starts to write,
but then he rereads homer.
And at first he feels terrible because
he realized that homer has said it all.
You know, there's two poems,
the Iliad and the Odyssey,
there's nothing left to say.
Homer has covered.
The entire homer has covered the
entire waterfront. And you know, so,
so what verbal is co Virgil is sort
of stock. What is he going to do?
Well,
what he can do if he can't imitate a
nature anymore because homer has done that
is he can imitate homer.
And the result is he comes to a sort of
realization that pope epitomizes in this
couplet.
But when to examine every part he came,
that is to say every part
of Homer's compositions,
every part of his own composition as
he undertook to write his own epic,
when to examine every part he came,
nature and homer were,
he found the same.
And so here you have emerging the idea
that to imitate nature and to imitate
art, to imitate the things of
the world, people of the world,
and to imitate language is part
and parcel of the same process.
To do one you necessarily
and perforce do the other.
And that's what I mean
by saying that we still,
we're still struggling to get away
from the logo genetic model to the
psychogenetic model.
We are still,
even in the most traditional expressions
of how influence works like pokes.
We are still concerned, uh, to, uh,
to distinguish and find it very difficult
to distinguish between nature and art.
Uh, when Samuel Johnson, uh,
50 years after pope is still saying
nothing can please many or please long,
but just representations
of general nature.
He is in this idea of representations
and in the idea of general nature
teetering between a sense that it's things
in the world that are imitates and it
is existing literary models that are
imitates and from which art takes its cue.
All right, so this, there's a kind
of collapse then of it in the,
in the idea of imitation,
there's a kind of a collapse,
a surprising collapse perhaps when
you think about it between, uh,
the notion of the imitation of nature
and the notion of the imitation of art.
Now when we,
we turn then to the two texts
that you read for today,
both of which are theories of influence,
uh,
you can see that ts Elliot to,
is a little bit unclear
as to the relationship of
these two sorts of imitation
for Elliot. The individual
talent that inserts itself into,
that engages with tradition has to
cope with what Eliot calls the mind of
Europe.
Page five 39 lefthand column.
I'll read a fairly extensive
passage because this is one of the,
one of the most accessible
summaries of what Elliot has to say.
The poet must be quite aware of the
obvious fact that art never improves,
but the, but that the material of art,
am I in the place I want to be in? Yes,
but that the material of
art is never quite the same.
He must be aware that the mind of Europe,
the mind of his own country,
a mind which he learns in time to be
much more important than his own private
mind.
And let me just stop there and say,
this seems as much unlike bloom as it
can possibly be because bloomed the
romantic, you know, there's all
about one's own private mind,
the struggle of the individual
mind to define itself over against,
uh,
all of those mines,
jostling for attention that preceded to
overcome them to the point where they
are in effect he faced.
And the belated, uh, ego,
uh,
can finally establish itself
as prior to all preceding egos.
I mean,
this sort of struggle scenes and I say
seems because I'm going to be lingering
over this for a while,
seems to be absent from Elliot.
Elliot seems to be all about selfie face
meant about the recognition that the
mind of Europe is more
important than one's own mind.
That if one is to contribute anything
as an individual talent to tradition,
that contribution has to be
a matter of the most, uh,
acutely sensitive,
uh,
awareness of everything.
Not that one is struggling to be,
but that one is not.
Uh,
it seems in other words like a very
different perspective to continue the
passage, uh, is a mind.
The mind of Europe is a mind which changes
and that this change is a development
which abandons nothing on route,
which does not superannuation
either Shakespeare or homer
or the rock drawing of
the Magdalena Ian draftsman.
This is a development refined that
this development refinement perhaps
complication certainly is not from
the point of view of the artist.
Any improvement.
In other words,
the relationship between tradition and
the individual talent is a relationship
of entering into a vast
matrix of literary,
philosophical,
uh,
and other sorts of expression that
changes and yet never really transforms
itself and certainly can't be understood
as a grand march or progress toward
some great goal because nothing is ever
lost and nothing radically innovative
can ever really be introduced.
I hope you're thinking in, in,
in reflecting on a passage of this kind
about a good deal that we've passed
through already got hammered
sense of tradition, uh,
as something which depends absolutely
on the awareness of continuity,
on the willingness to meet
the past half way, uh,
to enter into a merger of horizons,
uh,
in which the past and the present can
speak in an authentic way to each other.
Uh, and that, um, in
other ways this, uh, this,
this idea or possibly also the
Russian formalist idea, uh,
and it's Darwinian sense that the
dominant and the recessive elements of any
literary texts are always present
at any time. It's just that, uh,
they tend perpetually in a
kind of oscillation to be
changing places with each
other.
So the whole gamut of literary
possibility of expressive possibility is
according to theories of,
of history of this kind is always already
there and one's own entry into this
vast sea of expressive possibility is
always a subtle thing that certainly can't
in any way be seen to showcase or to
manifest any sort of original genius,
uh, as the romantic tradition might
want to insist on it. All right,
so this,
I this,
this is basically the perspective
of Elliot and one. Um,
and, and, and one from which,
uh, certainly, you know, uh,
bloom would obviously
seem to be diverging.
Now I want to say, I want
to argue that actually, uh,
there's a tremendous amount of continuity
between Elliot and bloom and that
blooms a tradition in the balloons.
Sorry, anxiety of influence.
I've never discussed this
with health, by the way. I,
those of you who may be taking
his seminars, I, you know,
I leave it up to you whether you want
to take this up with him. You know, I,
you know, I, as I say, I leave that
up to you. Um, but I think, um,
I think a strong argument can be
made and I have made it in print.
So Harold has seen it,
uh, that, uh, that, uh,
bloom misreads is a strong
ms reader of ts Elliot,
which is to say such as the
logic of strong misreading the,
that said everything bloom
has to say already. And I do,
despite this extraordinary appearance
of total difference in perspective,
the traditional versus the
romantic, uh, and so on. Um,
and I don't want to go into detail in
this argument for fear of being considered
obsessive, but I, I'd, I'd, I'd like to,
I'd like to make a few points about it
in passing because I think it's such a
perfect exemplification of how
the anxiety of influence works.
Bloom has always denied the influence
of traditional tradition and the
individual talent. He said, I mean,
he acknowledged his influences,
but there Amerson Nicha the great
romantic poets and so on. Uh,
but, and, and he's, as I say them and
were denied the, the influence of Elliot.
And yet as one reads, Elliot, I'm going
to spend some time with Elliot. Now.
It seems to me that at least in
skeletal form, in suggestion,
bloom is all there already,
which is after all,
all bloom ever says about the relationship
between a precursor and a belated
writer. So it can't beat surprising
Kenneth all right now, um,
now first of all, a bloom of course, uh,
it's very important to bloom,
uh,
to show the way in which the new
reconstitutes the old that is to say the
appropriation of the precursor text,
which is not unknown optional text,
although it,
and that's one of the things that's
sort of counter about, about blooms, uh,
writing in this period. He insists that
there is a particular precursor text.
I mean, you know, the precursor texts
for Tintern Abbey has listed us,
don't tell me about other precursor
tax. It's less of this. And he shows,
he shows how this is the case.
So the,
but the relationship between the belated
text and the precursor text is such
that we can never read the
precursor taxed the same way again.
The,
the,
the strong misreading of the precursor
text is so powerful and other words that
it becomes our strong misreading.
We just can't think about,
listen this in the same way on this view,
after we've read Tintern Abbey,
and I mean if, and if this seems
counterintuitive, um, just, I mean,
just think they think about certain
examples that might come to mind. Um,
the most obvious example
is the famous as is,
is the famous text by bore has called
Prm and our author of Don Quixote,
I imagine a number of, you
know, that text, but, uh,
what it consists in basically is,
uh,
it's a kind of an anecdote
about a freshmen writing. I,
as I recall in the end of the
19th century, uh, in Spanish,
uh, a text and this text
is, as it turns out,
verbatim word for word Cervantes,
Don Quixote, all it's not
Cervantes. Don Quixote is pyramid.
Ours don't Don Quixote and think how
different it is. This is a Frenchman,
the end of the 19th century, a
Frenchmen writing in Spanish. Ooh,
that's pretty impressive.
Much more impressive than Cervantes,
merely writing and his own
language, you know? And,
and it's a completely different
historical perspective,
whereas Cervantes thinks he's being a
little bit ironic about his own historical
moment. You know, the death
of chivalry and all that.
Think about how ironic you can be about
that historical moment writing several
centuries later with everything that
you know now. I mean it's, I mean,
what a tour de force to be able to
write don Quixote at the end of the 19th
century in another language, a toll, a
whole new ballgame. How can you read?
How can you ever read so Avantis
Don Quixote in the same way?
It seems naive right now. That's now
that's not the point of the store.
The front of the story is actually to
be little pyramid are, but this is, but,
but you can see this as a,
as a theory of strong mystery pyramid pay.
I'm on our thinks he's doing
something new. All right.
Fact is he's not doing
anything new at all.
His belief that he's doing something
new is precisely his misreading of the
precursor taxed. And yet, and by the way,
you don't have to have
read the precursor text.
You don't have to have read
the precursor to it's precise.
It's precisely his misreading
of the precursor tech.
But that miss reading after all
is something in it's very power,
which, uh, as it were,
infiltrates our own understanding of the
precursor text making it impossible for
us to read it the same way again.
Think of Joyce's Ulysses and we all
know that you listened his life.
Virgil's Aeneid is based on
the odyssey that it as it were,
recycles the Odyssey.
But it seems to be looking at the Odyssey
through the wrong end of a telescope.
I mean, it's just, I mean
it's dragging all the,
all the sort of heroic dimension of the
poem down into a kind of nitty gritty
account of everyday life
in recent society. And,
and, and in other words, it's
it implicitly, precisely.
And following the artists,
he debunks the heroic myth of the Odyssey.
How can we read, in other words,
the Odyssey in the same way, again,
after we've read, you'll listen. He's now,
it has to be said in bloom would say this.
Ulysses is not a strong misreading
of the odyssey because it's perfectly
conscious of what it's doing.
It knows exactly what it's doing with
respect to the text of the Odyssey.
So it's a, so it's a, it's
a deliberate misreading, uh,
which has other virtues is
not quite the same thing,
but what it does have in common with
blooms theory and what it has in common
also with Elliot idea about
the relationship between
the individual talent and
tradition is that it
reconstitutes tradition.
It makes us see,
it doesn't just provide something novel.
It makes us see tradition
itself, uh, in a different way.
Page five, 38, the right hand column,
about halfway down the existing monuments
says Elliot Forum an ideal order among
themselves,
which is modified by the
introduction of the new,
the really new work of art among them.
The existing order is
complete before the new year.
New Work arrives for order to persist
after the supervision of novelty.
The whole existing order must be,
if ever so slightly altered.
We can't quite see it the same way again.
So it's,
it's a dynamic mutual relationship between
tradition and the individual talent,
the strong precursor and they'd
be laded poet in each case,
which is mutually transforming and the,
and the basis,
the principle of transformation as the
belated poets strong misreading of the
precursor,
which simultaneously
asserts the egotistic,
the egoistic priority of the belated poet.
I'm doing something new,
I'm going where no one has ever
gone before and I'm doing so,
so powerfully that it's a question
whether there actually was anybody before,
uh,
on the one hand and the strong precursor
who turns out as one reflects more and
more and more about the relationship to
have said everything the belated poet
says already,
right.
So simultaneously a what blooms
theory of literary history,
his literary historiography places a
premium on innovation and on conservatism
or tradition simultaneously unlike God,
them are leaning toward the
conservative or traditional,
either Lee or the Russian formalists
leaning toward the innovative,
the blooming and idea simultaneously
countenances the idea of tradition as
something absolutely continuous and
also of tradition as something which is
constantly being remade
or at least rethought.
And that I have to tell you is
very similar to TSL, its position.
So now again,
you know the famous aphorism
of Elliot on page five 39,
uh, the lefthand column at
the bottom, someone said,
the dead writers are remote from us
because we know so much than they did
precisely. And they are that which
we know rather good. I think, uh,
the famous aphorism of Tsl,
it can also be understood as something
that bloom in his own way might very well
say.
The past is what we know,
but we're not aware of knowing it.
In other words,
I write the past when I
write my belated poem,
but I don't think I'm doing it.
I think instead that
I'm doing something new,
I am in the first revisionary ratio clean.
Amen.
I am swerving from the past.
I swerve out and down.
I find my own space,
like a Lucretia Adam.
I mean if it weren't for swerving
and Lucretia says, you know,
all the items would fall in the same
place, that wouldn't be good. So,
so they all swerve so they can all fall
in their own place. Well that's the,
that that is the belated poets sense
of what he's doing in relation to the
precursor. He's swerving out and
down from the precursor port, uh,
from the precursor put.
Uh, but of course he's not,
and we'll come back to this. He's not,
he's actually falling in the same place,
but the strength of that swerve,
the rhetorical gesture of the swerve is
so powerful that we do feel transported.
Once again.
We feel both at once.
The innovation and the
necessary conservative
conservatism or preservational
aspect of the new poets composition.
All right. So, um,
I think as I say that this
too is very much that, that,
that Elliot's aphorism too,
very much anticipates blooms view,
uh,
of the agonistic struggle among poets.
And then finally, you know, La is
famous emphasis and this of course,
nothing could seem to be
less bloomin'. And this, uh,
Elliot's famous emphasis on the poets
impersonality on the wish to escape
personality a lot. Of course he
says right hand column, page five,
41 and of section two.
But of course,
only those who have
personality. Any emotions? No.
What it means to water escape from these
things. Uh, you know, in other words,
to enter a world of art and
effect, to abandoned, uh,
the sense that what's important
is, uh, my personal, uh,
psychological agony to,
uh, to, to enter, uh,
by contrast the mind of
Europe to recognize the
complete insignificance of any
individual mine, certainly my own, uh,
and to immerse oneself as a poet,
as an artist,
as a creator, if one can
still retain this term, uh,
in that which is,
uh,
infinitely more vast than one is oneself.
Well,
that doesn't sound very bloomin',
but look on page 1160,
the right hand column,
add blooms a third revisionary race,
yo
a [inaudible] or maybe it's
Kenosis. Huh? We'll see in a minute.
Soon as I can find the page 1160,
that's cases and it's the
fifth revisionary ratio. Uh,
he's talking about,
he's talking about what the later poet,
the belated poet does,
uh,
in order to find a defined
space for himself. What,
what can I do in order to make
myself different from other people?
While you would think the answer would
be make yourself bigger than anybody.
I mean,
Wallace Stevens has a
wonderful poem called rabbit
as King of the ghosts and the
rabbit swells up.
Uh,
so to become so big that it just
kind of overwhelms everything.
And I always think of this as blooms,
belated poet, but if you have, but, but,
but if you have,
um,
a ski races as one of the
authentic revisionary ratios,
something very different is
happening to this same and, uh,
about halfway through the
definition definition five, um, he,
and by the way, the, uh,
the masculine pronoun is something that
Harold has never apologized for. Uh,
what he means is that a poet, um, is
gendered masculine, but that of course,
any woman can be a poet.
Uh,
we'll come back to distinctions
of that sort of later.
He does think of Emily Dickinson,
for example, as a strong poet. Uh,
but it's obviously that's a controversial
aspect of Bloom's work, but he,
but he uses the, he is as the
masculine prologue unapologetically.
And of course his theory is very much
caught up in the idea of oedipal conflict,
which as Freud is always being
criticized for is unless you,
uh,
unless you projected into the realm of
the symbolic as Lacan and feminists luck.
Candians Du do is undoubtedly a
masculinist idea. You know, the,
if the essential generational conflict of
human beings is between father and son,
well, you know, obviously, uh, problems
can be seen to arise from that. Um,
and uh, in Bloom's rhetoric in
his vocabulary, this, this, the,
the masculinist,
uh,
oedipal conflict is still
central in any case, uh,
returning to this point about the
effacement of the self in the very act of
trying to find a place for, for oneself
as an innovator and he faced which,
however,
once again seems to me to catapult bloom
back into the position of Elliot that
he is trying to misread strongly.
He says he yields the poet yields up
part of his own human and imaginative
endowment. In other words, he
curtails himself. He shrinks himself.
He makes himself less than he
might have been. Of course,
in order to be more than he has been,
he yields up part of his
own human and imaginative,
a dominant so as to separate
himself from others,
including the precursor.
So in,
in [inaudible] and also in Kinosis.
By the way,
there is a self shrinking or self
effacement on the part of these particular
moves of strong misreading
with respect to the precursor.
It's not another,
it's just a question of the rabbit as
king of the ghost is not a question of a
massive ego,
uh,
swelling to the point
where it fills all space.
It is more complicated than that.
And in being more complicated,
it is frankly more
Elliot. Like, all right,
so turning then more directly to a bloom,
his career begins his car.
It has always involved a sense of struggle
in their relationship among poets.
In his earliest work, uh, uh,
Shelley's mythmaking Blake's apocalypse
visionary company and his earliest work,
uh,
the idea of struggle was embodied
plainly as what he called Protestantism.
In other words,
he saw the tradition he was talking
about arising in relation to the
reformation. Uh, that
time when, as I said,
in my thumbnail history of
Hermeneutics, uh, everybody,
everybody suddenly realized he had his
own Bible, his own relationship with God.
And other words that time
when human, uh, individuality,
uh, emerges also of course
called by many others.
The emergence of the
bourgeoisie in that moment,
the idea of Protestantism purely in the
sense as a character in DRL says that I
protest, uh, emerges
so that each poet, uh,
takes in some sense and adversary
stance toward previous literary models.
This is present in Bloom's work from
the beginning of his career. The, uh,
the,
the word Protestant gradually
gives way to the word revisionary.
And then, uh, that's the word that he
uses primarily in the visionary company,
for example.
Uh,
and then finally becomes the notion of
misreading the protest of the belated
figure is the protest,
which takes the form of transfiguring,
the precursor taxed,
uh,
in such a way that one can
find oneself to be original.
It is an oedipal struggle.
Now th th th this idea
of oedipal struggle,
which is largely unconscious,
is not new to bloom.
Just quickly to review the next
three passages on your sheet lawn,
Gina's the, uh, the author
who's actual identity,
we cannot quite determine,
uh, but who's on the sublime,
uh, an extraordinarily interesting
texts is available to us to read. Um,
I've got two passages from him.
The first is,
as if instinctively this is
in the moment of the sublime,
as if instinctively our soul is
uplifted by the true sublime fine.
That's what you would
expect anybody to say.
It takes a proud flight and it's
filled with joy and vaunting.
And this is where the surprise comes as
though it had itself produced what it
has heard. And other words, there
is a kind of, they're there,
there's a kind of possession
by the other that takes place,
which is simultaneously
experienced psychologically
as possession of the other,
right. You know, it is speaking through
me. It's making me very excited.
Like a little kid,
you know,
the watching TV and somebody hits a home
run and the little kid goes like this
and thinks he thought he hit the
home run. I mean, he's, he's,
he's completely into the
fantasy of being that hero.
It's the same thing with the,
uh, with the response, uh,
to something that we haven't said so
such that in a certain moment we think we
have said it. It's a, it's,
it's a mutual possession.
It possesses us causing the psychological
reaction that we think of ourselves as
possessing it. And that, uh, uh,
it seems to me that there's real insight
in what launch ionist is saying and
that it has and that it has an
important influence on Bloom's position.
Another passage from launch
dryness and a boat. And by the way,
I think what longe Anna says
here is absolutely true.
Plato is constantly abusing homer,
and yet nothing can be easier than to
show the ways in which the great Homeric
actions, uh, and even tropes, uh, uh, uh,
help shape platonic
thought. Uh, it's, it's,
it's a fascinating topic and
Laryngitis, it seems to me, again, uh,
is exactly right about it. There would
not have been so fine a bloom, sorry.
So find a bloom of perfection on
Plato's philosophical doctrines,
unless he had with all his heart and
mind struggled with homer for primacy.
He even thinks in bloom in terms of that,
of wanting to be first,
even though in some part of your
mind, you know, your second,
he even struggles for primacy showing
perhaps too much love of contention and
breaking a lance with him as it were,
but deriving some profit from the contest.
Nonetheless,
for as he says,
this strife is good for mortal mortals.
Quickly and more commonplace
example taking from, uh, uh, bird,
a famous acid, his called
what is a classic, which is
all about influence. There's,
you know, the, the, the tradition of
essays, uh, called what is a classic,
Eliot wrote a great one in 1944,
uh,
is very much a contribution to the
history of the theory of influence. Uh,
so sad bird rights,
uh,
Gerta spoke the truth when he remarked
that Byron great by the flow and source
of poetry feared that Shakespeare was
more powerful than him side. It's true.
Byron was always abusing Shakespeare,
fear that Shakespeare was more powerful
than himself and the creation and
realization of his characters.
He would have liked to
deny it the elevation,
so free from this as Gerda
talking the elevation,
so free from egoism irritated him.
He felt when near it that he could
never display himself at ease.
He never denied pope
because he did not fear him.
He knew that pope was an,
you know how short pope was.
He knew that pope was only
a low wall by his side.
So in other words,
he chose as his literary model,
somebody he knew he was better
than not true by the way,
but he thought he was
better than Alexander Pope.
And he perpetually denied a very,
very powerful influence on his writing.
Quarrelling constantly with Shakespeare
and Shakespeare and bar, dollar tree and,
and, uh, excessive love of hamlet
and all the rest of it. Um,
he's constantly sort of denying the any
influence or power over himself on the
part of Shakespeare he chooses and
other words for his precursor a week
precursor instead of a strong precursor.
And all of this is a continuous theme,
uh,
in the psychodynamic of, uh,
of, of Bloom's theory as,
as he elaborates it.
So what complicates bloons argument
apart apart from the vocabulary and the,
and the philosophical range of the
thought is what I began with this,
the traditional idea of uh,
influence as a,
as an art nature problem, trying
to figure out in fact whether, uh,
the,
uh,
whether the crisis of influence is the
sense of one's orientation to nature,
one's ability to imitate nature,
have nature available to one or whether
it's word or I added the sense of ones,
which it seems to be, uh, more in bloom,
the sense of one's
relationship with texts.
But notice on page 1157,
that blown really doesn't want
to say it's just about texts.
He doesn't really want to say that it,
that it has exclusively to do with the
strong precursor understood as it were,
as an author.
There is in some sense a
text of nature as well.
So that bloom says a bottom
of 1157 right hand column,
uh,
Freud's disciple auto rock shows a
greater awareness of the artists fight
against art end of the relation of this
struggle to the artist antithetical
battle against nature.
In other words,
nature is death.
Nature is that into which should he not
sustain himself in the triumph of his
assertion of priority.
Nature is that into,
it's the author will fall back into,
into in the form of death. Weight'll they
try to transcribe that sentence. Okay.
Well but, but, but you, you
got, you got what I mean? Um,
so, uh, and,
and this is an interesting problem and
bloom and bloom wants to insist that part
of the struggle of the belated
poet is a struggle for mortality.
Part of what it means to come first and
to know nothing ever having been there
before you is also to suppose
that you're going to be last,
that you're going to be immortal,
that you really do not
belong in an unfolding,
inexorable sequence of the
sort that we call history.
But that you are rather
something, a force, a genius,
a power that transcends history.
And this entails as much
the lie against time as bloom calls it,
holding off death as
it does, insisting, uh,
on their having been no beginning,
no priority,
no genesis in what you do.
You were there first or to
illustrate this very quickly,
let's look at passages
five and six on your sheet.
Wordsworth, uh, the
strong miss reader, uh,
and belated poet with respect to Milton,
uh,
the particularly important strong miss
reader a and belated put with respect to
Milton and blooms view Wilton,
right Wordsworth rights in a kind
of programmatic or promissory poem,
uh, written actually in
1800, not, not published, uh,
until 1814 as part of his,
as part of the preface to a poem
of his called the excursion. Uh,
he wrote a prospectus, uh, to the recluse.
That's what at one time they incur the
excursion was supposed to be part of.
And he says, I'm not interested
in writing. Paradise lost.
Paradise lost for me as a thing of the
past. It's just, it's just archaic.
Who would care about the things
Milton cares about all strength,
all terror,
single or in bands that ever was
put forth in Personal Form Jehovah.
Where this thunder and the choir of
shouting angels and the imperial Thrones,
I passed them on alarm,
paradise lost. You know,
so that's just playing with toy
soldiers. You know what I mean? That's,
that's that,
that,
that's nothing compared with
what I myself am going to do.
Not Chaos,
not the darkest pit of Lowest
Aramis nor ought of blinder vacancy.
Scooped out by help of dreams can breed
such fear and awe and has fall upon us.
Often when we look into our minds,
into the mind of man,
my haunt and the main region of my song,
I'm not talking about God.
I'm not talking about heaven.
I'm not talking about hell.
I'm not talking about war heaven.
I'm not talking about anything
mythological or archaically, heroic.
I'm talking about this.
I'm talking about the mind of man.
I'm talking primarily about my mind,
but my mind is your mind.
Mind is universal and
in talking about mind,
I'm not falling back
into the pit of nature.
I'm keeping my focus not on the
sky gods that on the transcendent,
you know,
so starry junk as well as Stephen
called it of my precursors,
all those people with their
outworn superstitions.
I am not interested in any of that, but
I'm not interested in any of this either.
I'm not interested in nature and I'm not
interested in that in which I would be
buried if I reduced myself to that.
I'm interested in consciousness,
the psyche. In other words, uh,
my focus is Wordsworth says,
altogether psychological.
All right,
no interest in paradise
lost. You know, that's just
archaic. Well, look at passage.
Five,
three statements by Satan,
which bloom and cysts are.
Say,
it's not so much Milton because at
bloom follows Blake and Shelly in this.
It's not so much Milton who's the
strong precursor of Wordsworth.
It's actually Satan.
It's Milton's Satan who says the mind is
its own place and in itself can make a
heaven of hell, a hell of
heaven. Okay. Gee whiz. I guess.
I guess Satan is writing the
perspectives to the recluse, isn't it?
Because that's what Wordsworth and saying
in the first practice to the recluse.
I know no time says Satan
when I was not as now.
That's what the belated
poet all with says.
I came first elsewhere in the poem.
Satan tells his troops,
you know what you God keeps
saying he created you. Do
you remember being created?
I don't remember being created.
I've always been there.
Right. You know, and that's,
and, and, and that is in
effect what he says again,
what he repeats in this passage.
Finally myself and hell.
Well that's of course rather
an uncomfortable thing to say,
but at the same time it's the rabbit
as king of the ghost, isn't it? It is.
You know, whatever you can throw at
me, I'm it already, right? That is, uh,
and because the sole region ma,
the main heart and soul region of
my song is the mind is my own mind.
Alright?
So Satan has already said in paradise
lost everything Wordsworth can possibly
say and the perspectives to the recluse.
He has strongly misread paradise lost
such that he thinks he's doing something
completely new while revealing precisely
that the strong precursor poet has
always already written what
the successor poet can,
right. The tension, the dynamic,
in other words between conservation
and innovation is intact in all such
moments.
In all of the moments that involve,
that involve the anxiety of influence.
I'm sorry,
I have so little time for this. Give
me a minute or two because we have to,
we have to honor Tony.
Uh,
and it's rather obvious
that for Lacan Tony,
the tow truck is a text in which Tony
Saddles for the orb. J Patea, right.
Little bumpy,
the car and imperfect being,
but a helpful one and a friend.
That's what I call a friend.
Whereas the objects of desire
neato speeding. Oh, you know,
uh,
those are cars.
The objects of the objects of desire are
improper object choices on the face of
it. That's what an American eat
ego psychologist would said,
but they are in a more Boone well esque
way of putting it obscure objects of
desire as they motor on down the road,
which are simply unavailable to Tony,
uh,
as object relations at all.
And so the Nido and
speedy are the big other,
right and bumpy is the
object t all right. Now, uh,
it's perfectly obvious that
for Harold Bloom, Tony,
the tow truck is a strong misreading
of the little engine that could, it's,
it's perfectly clear because,
you know,
but bumpy af is bumpy.
W is the hero of the
little engine that could,
the misreading involves
making Tony the hero, uh, uh,
who, who needs the help
of bumpy and other words,
bumpy in the folkloric sense of the story
becomes the helper, not the hero. Uh,
but, but, but,
but we can see after all that
the essential narrative model,
the model of, of the small, uh,
turning out through
perseverance and energy, uh, to,
uh, necessarily reinforce
the strength of the strong.
And it is about the strong and the weak,
both little engine that could and Tony
the tow truck or about the strong and the
weak, uh, that the strong, uh,
must in some sense or
another be supplemented or
supplanted by the week if the
strong is fully to self realized.
We can't ever read Tony the tow truck,
the character Tony,
quite the same way again
after the appearance of bumpy.
And yet bumpy is nothing other than the
hero of the little engine that could,
uh, who, who, uh,
a subject position that has been
appropriated by Tony in this text.
And so the relationship is
again, an agonistic one, uh,
involving the transposition of heroism
from one character focus to another while
at the same time as anybody can recognize
who read both stories to their kids.
Uh, well, at the same time,
simply rewriting the story in a way that
the little engine that could completely
anticipates all right.
Uh, so much then for that,
we'll be returning to more
Lacanian pastures on Tuesday, uh,
when we,
uh,
when we study their lives
and got Tommy and slower Gj.